hey guys it is Tuesday that the tenth of
January today my name is jeff mcdonald
and you're tuned into Game one news if
you're a fan of water chances are you'll
be interested in be just announced for
for motorsport 6 unsurprisingly coming
exclusively to Xbox one time 10 studios
and microsoft revealed that the newest
entry would be on its way during the
north american international auto show
the game was revealed alongside the new
Ford GT which also serves as the game's
cover car Ford will also have a bunch of
their performance cars in the upcoming
racing titles including the shelby gt350
mustang and the f-150 raptor turn turn
the promised we'll see more of the game
at e3 this year in news that
unfortunately proves we aren't leaving
the game delay trends back in 2014 GTA 5
PC has been delayed again the game was
initially supposed to release in fall of
last year which then became late January
of this year and is now slated to be on
shelves come March 24 regarding the
delay Rockstar have stated they require
a few extra weeks to test and polish the
game Rockstar explains moving a release
date is never a decision we take lightly
and is a choice we make only when we
know it is in the best interest of the
game and our fans thanks everyone for
your understanding and we assure you
these few extra weeks will be worth it
when the game does arrive in March
Rockstar have also released the minimum
and recommended pc specs which you can
check out in detail on games button and
an unexpected news the Xbox one has won
an Emmy Award the little black box has
taken home an award from the slightly
less popular Emmy Awards for technology
in engineering for its multimedia
capabilities specifically it was awarded
to the consoles television on demand
function the xbox one plays cds dvds and
a raise but also offers DLNA and MTV
support so you can stream downloaded
video files on the console by your pc or
via external storage hardware a feature
which no other next-gen console
currently offers let me know down in
that comment section which console you
would give an award to and why pc is
also totally a valid option you can add
to gain slots and more stories on Call
of Duty DLC and Last of Us remastered
bundle that is it for me today do let me
know what you cared about and I will
catch you same time tomorrow